Nepal began its day of national mourning
suffering the country's worst domestic
air crash in 30 years
rescue operations have been halted two
days running due to weather conditions
and Nightfall and will resume tomorrow
in the mangled wreckage authorities
found the aircraft's black box which
will help find the causes to the crash
so far no one has been found alive in
the ill-fated aircraft that crashed
short of Pokhara International Airport
today you can hear people shouting
unsure what to do as the plane burns the
yeti Airlines flight strewn across the
Ravine below them Nepal's prime minister
promising any help that's needed
yes
this was found by a passenger in those
final seconds hard to watch the plane
was also filmed from the ground close to
pokra airport you can see the aircraft
rolling sharply on its sides before it
disappears
just a minute
Nepal has had a poor track record of air
disasters 350 people have lost their
lives since the year 2000 in aircraft
and helicopter crashes across the
country the European Union imposing a
blanket ban on all Nepali Airlines into
its airspace since 2013.
we've got the highest mountains in the
world very deep valleys and a lot of our
the crashes that do occur are in very
tricky
flying in small planes in deep mountain
valleys uh often control flights into
terrain the crash yesterday was not one
of those
the new airport in Pokhara was designed
to capitalize on the area's popularity
with tourists
now distraught relatives instead
arriving desperate for information
Nepal's aviation industry has bombed in
recent times with tourists and Trekkers
descending on the country
but questions have been raised in the
past and now once again over safety
regulations of its aviation industry
Neville Lazarus Sky News
[Music]